israel cuenta con 14 formaciones
políticas el partido nacionalista de
derecha likud liderado por el primer
ministro en funciones benjamin netanyahu
es favorito para ganar las elecciones
pero necesitará gobernar en coalición
con los ultraortodoxos del judaísmo
unido de la torá el seas de los
ultraortodoxos sefardíes o el partido de
extrema derecha sionismo religioso
proyecciones les dan alrededor de 60
escaños para un total de 120 son
insuficientes para gobernar sin embargo
la subida en las últimas encuestas del
primer ministro por la gestión de las
vacunas la posibilidad de que algún
partido no supere el umbral mínimo del 3
25 por ciento de los votos o la
deserción de algún diputado opositor
podrían conseguir que netanyahu pueda
formar gobierno si finalmente el bloque
anti netanyahu consigue más escaños éste
contaría con antiguos aliados del líder
del likud estos son el ex ministro de
interior de netanyahu gideón saar del
partido nueva esperanza el ex ministro
de exteriores avigdor lieberman de
israel beiteinu y el también exministro
naftalí bennett del partido derechista
ya mina ideológicamente son cercanos a
netanyahu pero les separan grandes
personales sin embargo tampoco parece
que los partidos mantiene tan yahoo
puedan lograr mayorías lidera este
bloque el segundo partido en intención
de voto y este tipo de ya peer lápiz de
centroizquierda entre los anti netanyahu
están los laboristas los izquierdistas
de méretz y los partidos árabes la lista
conjunta formada por tres partidos
árabes además de la lista árabe unida
por último está el partido centroderecha
cajolá al 'bund' el socio del último
gobierno de netanyahu venid cannes quien
ha visto una gran caída en la intención
de voto y el nuevo partido económico que
todo indica que no va a entrar en la
knesset en este contexto hay espacio
para cuatro escenarios una mayoría
absoluta ultra derechista de benjamín
netanyahu la imposibilidad para ambos
bloques de formar gobierno una
improbable coalición ante netanyahu de
derecha a izquierda y partidos árabes y
finalmente que netanyahu termina
pactando con alguno de sus ex socios